una Nochebuena helada en Estados Unidos
el 60% de la población al menos 200
millones de personas han estado bajo
alguna alerta por la tormenta Elliot
las autoridades han instado a sus
ciudadanos a permanecer en casa
principalmente en la frontera con Canadá
asegúrese de hacer sus planes de
vacaciones para otro momento si aún está
Unido con su familia Porque la madre
naturaleza lanzó el refrigerador de la
cocina hacia nosotros esta vez
la tormenta es causada por un frente de
aire Ártico desde Canadá hasta Texas
pronosticando temperaturas de hasta 13
grados bajo cero varios estados de la
costa este como Florida y Texas podrían
vivir las navidades más gélidas desde
que se tienen registro
la congelación de la infraestructura
eléctrica del país ha dejado a más de
1.5 millones de usuarios a oscuras
en cuanto al transporte las carreteras
han colapsado además la cancelación de
al menos 4000 vuelos impide que miles de
pasajeros se reúnan con sus familias en
Navidad
me retrasé aquí debido a la loca
tormenta a donde voy acabo de escuchar
que se ha inundado por lo que no es el
momento adecuado para que entre ahora
Así que no ha sido una visita fácil en
este momento en particular pero rezo
para que todo se calme
según los pronósticos del servicio
meteorológico nacional habrá mejores
condiciones los próximos días